Bob Costas Hall of Fame broadcaster and
MLB Network has launched a new series
it's called sounds of baseball co-hosted
by Bob and Tom Verducci and you look
back on some of the greatest calls
moments from great broadcasters Ben
Scully was featured first Jack buck Bob
Uecker and others will follow Bob
joining us on the program good morning
Bob how's your morale not too bad not
too bad all things considered you we're
kind of getting used to it you know just
waiting it out and seeing what's going
to happen but you're waiting for
baseball to come back what do you do all
day
well I've been able to read more outside
sports and outside preparation than I
used to because there isn't that much to
prepare for you know we spend so much
time I'm sure we're very much alike in
this respect reading newspapers reading
magazines not enough time to delve into
books and over the last many weeks I've
been able to do that deal with a lot of
people are doing catching up on stuff
that's on Netflix or old movies or
whatever it may be and you know that's
pretty much it watching some of the
archival games that show up on the all
sports networks and what you just
mentioned is one of the great labors of
love
ever I don't know if you were able to
catch it I'm sure they'll repeat it the
two hours with Vin Scully drew such a
response you know during the last dance
or whatever you're I'd hear from a lot
of people because that was being watched
by millions of people but the response
to this among whatever sized audience
happened to catch it on a Monday night
on MLB Network really shows that that
VIN is in a category all his own and the
way people respond to this kind of
programming it's nostalgic but it's also
new it's just a different way in its not
a just a series of clips and highlights
we try to get to kind of the mosaic of
what made him different and what made
him tremendous and there's so much
baseball history going back to 1950 and
so much broadcasting history really and
I hope we provided some insight into
that beyond just here's a great play or
here's a great game and here's a great
call of it we talked about this I think
the last time we talked that social
media would probably be very critical of
Vin Scully
I mean they're critical of everybody
here but yeah to have that kind of voice
and would we allow a voice like that now
in in baseball
or in sports I don't know that he could
flourish on network TV if that's where
he landed first in fact one of the
points we made and maybe I told you this
story on one of our other visits at some
point along the way that one of the
points we made was that Dodger telecasts
in the last 20 years or so when he was
just doing games mostly home games
because he wasn't traveling that much
anymore
those telecasts were directed and
produced from the inside out he didn't
have to follow graphics and production
elements they followed him with rare
exceptions and I mentioned on this
special one occasion where he was
telling a story about Don Zimmer who had
only passed away a few days before and
in the middle of it Scott Van Slyke of
the Dodgers gets hit by a pitch big deal
the benches didn't empty wasn't being
they didn't charge the mallet he goes
down to first base no matter how good
the producer or director that happens
today in any baseball game they show it
from three or four different angles but
that would a truncated Ben story he just
noted that that's like he'd been hit he
goes down to first base he continues
with this four or five minute
remembrance of of Don Zimmer and even
the network games and there are plenty
of them on this special at the time and
I did about then even the network games
are less cluttered than they are now
some of the games that the archival
games that I did in the 1990s that have
been played on the major league baseball
network you can't help but notice if you
have any interest in broadcasting how
relatively uncluttered there they are
are their replays when necessary yeah
are there graphics yeah but you don't
need a pitch box at a strike zone box on
every single play you don't need to
perform an autopsy on every ground ball
to shortstop and that allows a broadcast
to breathe and allows the broadcaster to
do whatever he is most able to do you
look at Bob Uecker z-- career and I he
was a novelty when he was on with Carson
and he was so self-deprecating
beer commercials like thankfully you
know it's one of those where you go how
did this happen
but it happened like dick vital happened
if you said hey we're gonna this guy is
going to be a star like why did Bob
Uecker resonate with people not only
locally but nationally well first of all
he's just so damn funny
you think of the major-league movies
Basel III even euchre says you should
forget about but major league one was
fantastic Major League two was good and
euchre is a huge reason why he's the guy
who snitches the whole thing together
and he had lived at least half of it
they give him just the general script
that he'd think of funny things to say
Carson was only a so-so baseball fan but
he loved euchre many people who played
with him on the Braves or the Cardinals
of the Phillies say to this day that
he's the funniest person they've ever
been around that he's just that funny in
person even funnier in some respects
that he is on the air but here's what a
lot of people miss if they only know him
from Johnny Carson of a major league
movies or the commercials
he's just straight-up a really good
baseball announcer you listen to his
calls of big plays with the Brewers he's
on top of the game it's different than
Scully you know VIN and others I tried
to prepare as hard as I could
Al Michaels you know you prepares by
going in the clubhouse hanging around a
batting cage goes upstairs takes a look
at the game notes that they hand out in
the press box fills out a lineup card
and just wings it but his broadcast even
if he wasn't as funny as he is his
broadcasts are first-rate and still and
he's 86 years old talking to Bob Costas
I know we keep talking about baseball I
said it's it's kind of a verbal game of
ping-pong back and forth we go and I
don't know where we end up but it feels
like 75 something in that area feels
like common ground here but the
back-and-forth being made public it
feels like baseball has everything's
leaked out like we're the NBA kept
everything quiet for about three weeks
and now they're on the verge of coming
back like I don't know what this
strategy is a major league baseball or
the Players Association but if you were
going to be an arbitrator here mediator
how would you bring both sides together
well one of the things you have to point
out is they're moving toward if it makes
that much difference to the players to
be able to say that they won some sort
of nominal victory by saying we're
getting prorated a hundred percent
prorated or some portion close to a
hundred percent of what would have been
prorated if it's that important to them
figure out what the actual pool of money
would be under any of these other
proposals and if you need it to save
face to say that you got the prorated
portion we're just going to keep
calibrating it until we get to the
number where you can claim that victory
and walk away you know these two sides
seem determined to drive off a cliff and
they seem yet again determined that I
thought it might have been better
because they had not a work stoppage in
a long time I thought there was a better
relationship but there's so much lasting
mistrust between the sides it's been
passed down through the generations I
think it's particularly true of the
players at this point moreso than than
the owners and the Commissioner
historically the players were right I
don't think either side can claim any
moral high ground in this situation you
know the players talking about we were
promised prorated but it specifically
says in the agreement that they struck
in spring training when Cova 19 first
hit that if they had to play without
fans they would revisit it then they
claim all this will establish some sort
of revenue sharing or backdoor salary
cap of the future kind of claim is that
the owners intend to play without fans
in the future do they intend to play
with teams competing only in their own
time zones these are all one offs these
are all just for now and what you you're
pointing out is correct not only is the
bickering making them look bad but if in
fact that bickering keeps them from
playing at all or if it reduces them to
a number of games that would be a
mockery because we know that baseball is
different from basketball or hockey or
even football in that respect you need
some representative number of games to
say that okay we've determined even in
this one offseason we've determined that
that's enough to launch a postseason
from there
the Nats were 19 and 31 after 50 games
last year and they wound up winning the
World Series
you got to play a representative number
of games before there's any authenticity
at all even in a unique season like this
and the big picture you know a year from
now they're going to have to sit down
and hammer out another CBA and no matter
who walks away from the table now and
says well I guess we got the better of
this negotiation if the business itself
is damaged then everybody is damaged and
if a business thrives then everybody
does better the owners won some
concessions in the last couple of
negotiations I've made the ones but some
can we say that the players didn't
thrive of course they they continued to
thrive and what they got to see now and
a forest for the trees situation is this
no matter what even if they've done
everything perfectly they were able to
play 82 games and everyone everyone was
on the same page and and they're all
making the best of it they're still
going to take an economic hit next
season and maybe beyond because people
are going to have less discretionary
income some will be less willing to come
to games just as there'll be less women
to go to concerts and other gatherings
there's going to be an economic hit and
instead here they are squabbling over
small things and not seeing the
importance of the big things our
over-under our poll question is over
under 75 games for baseball this season
where do you stand that seems about
right
that seems yeah you talk about an
over/under could it land under that yeah
I take the under okay
I'm not I'm not saying it won't be 75
but it'd be very optimistic to land
higher than 75 I think percentage that
we don't have a season this year would
be what in your opinion small but not
impossible 10% 20% yeah it's just you
know the clock is ticking and it feels
like we set these arbitrary dates and go
okay if you don't start by now and then
you don't start by now I don't know if
you don't start by now that it truly
means if you don't start by now that you
won't get a season in because you're
going to get dwarfed by you know hockey
coming back golf is coming back
back you're gonna have the NBA coming
back in the postseason then you got
College in the NFL and baseball gets
lost usually in those months anyways
they have their sweet spot usually in
you know July or June in July or July
and August here and that that's
dangerous too
if you come back and you're not relevant
after everything that you've gone
through yeah they could have had it if
they did it in a way that seemed as if
they were on the same page as we said
they could have had the stage to
themselves among team sports for a while
and that would have been a boost and the
owners are very keen on finishing before
going deep into November they proposed
the regular season I'd ends toward the
end of September expanded playoffs maybe
with as many as 16 teams so it'll take a
little while to get through that but
they really don't want to be playing you
know into Thanksgiving or heaven forbid
into December
not just because they'd be up against
other sports but because they fear no
one knows for sure but they fear a surge
in the coronavirus and perhaps being
derailed which could happen to any sport
at any time so you know they're looking
at a window of getting in enough games
for it to be credible then finished with
an expanded postseason and get out of
the way hopefully before something else
knocks them off course you ever called a
game in the snow oh yeah yeah a baseball
game yeah yeah yeah in fact in fact
during the 1997 World Series there were
snow flurries and temperatures in the
30s in Cleveland it was the Marlins
against the Indians and every game in
Cleveland our teeth were chattering up
in the food and every game in Florida it
was like 85 degrees a complete contrast
I remember at one point this is the rare
situation where I may have said
something funnier than what you
Christina at that exact moment he was
commenting on how cold it was and I said
I glanced down in the stands and a
half-dozen of the tests concession
people are Saint Bernard
Luka said this is a really nice skate
night for a game if you're a penguin and
then the next night kind of storm and
Keith
hosted pregame and they came on the air
with an actual penguin on the set with
them and it wasn't burgess Meredith
Danny hey thanks for joining us Bob
hopefully we got some movement here
sometime soon
with baseball but great to talk to you
Thank You bud you daddy well that's Bob
Costas Hall of Famer and of course he
spent 40 years at NBC